[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
concentration dans les médias en france
la commission d' enquête a commencé ses
travaux
rapprochement du groupe lagardère avec
vivendi projet de fusion entre tf1 et m6
des acteurs puissants des médias veulent
être capable de concurrencer les géants
mondiaux du secteur notamment en
mutualisant les coûts
mais une telle concentration ne
risque-t-elle pas de compromettre
l'indépendance et la diversité des
lignes éditoriales
pour y voir plus clair le sénat a créé à
la demande du groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains une
commission d' enquête chargée d'estimer
la réalité de la concentration des
médias et d'évaluer si ce phénomène
porte atteinte au principe
constitutionnel de liberté
d'indépendance et de pluralisme
david assouline rapporteur s'inquiètent
en effet de savoir si les journalistes
qui composent les rédactions dispose de
garanties d'indépendance suffisamment
efficace face à des actionnaires qui
pourraient avoir la tentation
d'intervenir
dans le cadre de cette commission
denquête instituée en décembre 2021 il
s'agira ainsi de comprendre le paysage
médiatique qui se dessine en replaçant
ce phénomène de concentration dans un
environnement mondial et en mesurant ses
conséquences sur l'organisation du
secteur
laurent lafon président de la commission
souligne quant à lui la nécessité de
disposer d'un constat lucide et
actualisées dans l'optique de la
révision du cadre légal des opérations
de concentration qui paraît aujourd'hui
obsolète compte tenu des évolutions
technologiques juridiques et
internationale
la commission denquête entamera ses
auditions dès le début du mois de
décembre
elle entendra les dirigeants et des
actionnaires des principaux médias ainsi
que des journalistes des experts les
pouvoirs publics et les régulateurs
pour en savoir plus consultez les
travaux de la commission d' enquête
[Musique]